اذا مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه
للتطورات المشهد السوداني تجددت مره اخرى
اصوات الانفجارات وكذلك ذوي اطلاق النار
في محيط قياده الجيش السوداني بالعاصمه
الخرطوم وايضا في مواقع اخرى من العاصمه
السودانيه وفي خدم هذه التطورات الميدانيه
ما فتئ الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
بتبادل الاعلان عن السيطره على هذا الموقع
او ذاك قوات دعم السريع اعلنت بدورها
اسقاط طائره مسيره بقاعده جري العسكريه
الشمال العاصمه الخرطوم بحري فيما اعلن
الجيش السوداني سيطرته على كافه مقرات قوه
دعم السريع بالمدينه قبل ان يطالب الجيش
المواطنين باخلاء المنازل الواقعه في محيط
مبنى التلفزيون السوداني بالعاصمه الخرطوم
اما على صعيد الخسائر البشريه اعلنت نقابه
اطباء السودان ارتفاع عدد قتل الاشتباكات
الى 27 قتيلا فضلا عن اصابه 183
الاخرين فيما بدات معاناته المدنيين تتكشف
بشكل تدريجي كل هذه الامور تاتي وسط حديث
عن عالقنا في المدارس والمعاهد التعليميه
وكذلك انقطاع للمياه وايضا التيار
الكهربائي في عدد من احياء العاصمه
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا للوقوف على اخر تفاصيل
المشهد السوداني معنا من الخرطوم مراسل
العربيه السلم الهاشمي سالم يعني يبدو
بانه اذان حتى الاذان الاولي للفجر في
السودان لم يمنع اصوات الرصاص من
في السودان وكذلك اصوات القذائف التي حتى
هذه اللحظه ما زالت تسيطر على الاجواء في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ما الجديد الذي
لديك سلام
نعم الجديد هو تجدد الاشتباكات في ام
درمان في الساعه الاخيره من الليل
تجددت هذه الاشتباكات لاستماع لعيره ناريه
والقنابل كذلك ايضا الجديده ان نقابه
الاطباء هيئه الكهرباء لاعاده التيار
لمستشفى ابراهيم مالك بالخرطوم لجهه وجود
مرضى بالعنايه المكثره ومصابون بحاجه
لتدخل جراحي وانقطاع التيار الكهربائيه
حول دون ان يقوم الاطباء بدورهم في داخل
المستشفى الان مناسبات يعني تتوالى حول
هذا الموضوع في مستشفى ابراهيم مالك ووجود
مرضى في العنايه المكثفه بكل تاكيد
يحتاجون للكهرباء وربما في الساعات
الماضيه تم التعامل معه
المولدات لكن يمكن ان ينفذ الوقود الذي
تزود به هذه المولدات او اذا كانت تعمل
ببطاقه البطاريات التي تخزن فيها الطاقه
كذلك تكون قد نفذت حتى الان بان الساعات
الان يعني
من ال 24 ساعه من قطاع التيار الكهربائي
ايضا الجديد ابناء واحده من الشبكات
للاتصالات انقطعت فيها الخدمات الانترنت
والاتصالات وهي شبكه انت فقط شبكتين وهي
سوداني وزين ما زالت فيهما الخدمه لكن في
امكاننا الانترنت والاتصالات انقطع فيها
الاتصال وكذلك
الان هناك شبكه توقفت تماما عن العمل في
في الخرطوم فقط ام في كل المدن السودانيه
يظهر انه يعني يظهر انه بكل السودان
انقطاع خدمه
عن تزويد
اصحاب الشرائح
بالاتصالات والانترنت فيما يتعلق بالشبكات
الاخرى هل هي تعمل
بكامل طاقته بالانترنت
تعمل بكل طاقتها بالاتصالات لكن الانترنت
فيه تدبب واضح جدا الا بطرق واساليب كثيره
جدا يتم بعد ذلك عمل الانترنت في العاصمه
ام في كل المدن السودانيه كذلك
في كل المدن السودانيه واضح في خدمات
يعني ارجو ان تبقى معي سالم ونحن على
الهواء مباشره لان هناك صوت لقصف يتجدد
الان وكذلك صوت اليات ينتشر بشكل مكثف في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وتحديدا في
محيط مقر قياده الجيش السوداني الان على
الهواء مباشره لنستمع اذا للصوت الطبيعي
ونحن قبل دقائق معدوده من اذان الفجر في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم طبقا للتوقيت
المحلي هناك
كما تتابعون الان على الهواء مباشره هذه
هي اصوات القذائف وكذلك هناك من الصوت
يبدو وكان هناك اليات ثقيله تتحرك في
الشوارع المحيطه بمقر قياده الجيش
السوداني بالعاصمه الخرطوم وكذلك كما
تابعتم قبل قليل هناك يبدو بعض العناصر
التي تتحصل على اسطح المباني التي ترصدها
كاميرا العربيه على الهواء مباشره الان من
محيط مقر قياده الجيش السوداني بالعاصمه
الخرطوم لا نعلم ماهيه هذه المباني تحديدا
هل هي مباني عسكريه ام مباني مدنيه لكن
الواضح بشكل
حقيقي يعني واظهرت هذه الامور يعني
الكاميرا العربيه اظهرت هذه الصور قبل
لحظات قليله بعض العناصر تتحصن على اسطح
هذه المباني وكان على ما يبدو هناك اطلاق
نار كثيف من اسطح هذه المباني فيما يبدو
انه المناوشات تزداد حدتها شيئا فشيئا مع
الساعات الاولى
الفجر وصباح هذا اليوم في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم اعود اليك مره اخرى
سالم يعني يبدو وكانوا اصوات القصف تتجدد
ويتبدد معها الامال بانه كل الاطراف الان
لا يبدو انها لديها اي رغبه في
تلبيه النداءات الدوليه والاقليميه التي
تكررت منذ ساعات وحتى هذه اللحظه بضروره
وقف اطلاق النار هل حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يبدي اي طرف من اطراف الازمه في السودان
مجرد ولو قبول مبدئي بفكره اطلاق النار او
حتى
بمجرد هدوء ولو نسبي
نعم حتى هذه اللحظه اي مظاهر لمساله
التنازل لان الجيش السوداني قد حدد موقفه
بانه لن يبقى حوارا متعلقا بهذا الامر
ايضا تبادل الاتهامات بين الطرفين توحي
بان مساله الحوار مستبعد تماما الجيش
السوداني اكد انه لن يوقف هذه العمليه حتى
يقضي على ميليشيات الدعم السريع بحسب وصف
الجيش السوداني
وتبادل الاتهامات بان الجيش السودانيه
يستهم قوات الدعم السريع بتمثيل
ومهاجمه القائد العام في مكان اقامته في
التاسعه صباحا من هذا اليوم وايضا الردود
التي ردت عليها قوات الدعم السريع من
قائدها كذلك
الجيش السوداني هو من اضطرهم للدخول
للمواجهه وانه بدا بمواجهتهم
وذكر بانه ذكر ايضا ذكر قوات الدعم لانها
ستواصل ملاحقه البرهان والعداله هذا ما تم
تداوله في نهار او اخر نهار امس تم تداول
مثل هذه الاخبار كل هذه الوحيده في اعلى
درجاتها على الارض ايضا التصعيد عالي جدا
هذا القصف الذي كان بالامس على مناطق
مقرات الدعم السريع في صالحه وفي كرري ما
زالت المواجهه حتى الان
يعني في منطقه
اخر الليل تسمع
انفجارات وقنابل ثقيله جدا في منطقه حتى
المنطقه منطقه
القاطنين هناك الان في حاله زعر ورعب
حقيقي في تلك المناطق منطقه حتى لا منطقه
على شارع الوادي المناره الجراح كذلك
انتشرت مجموعه من الصور للاطفال وعرضناها
قبل قليل لاطفالي يختبئون يعني اسفل
الاسره في منازلهم ويبدو وكان هناك حاله
من الرعب تسيطر على العائلات في هذه
المناطق
هذه المناطق فيها ذعر شديد لان
الضربات فيها مكثفه جدا من الجيش السوداني
على منطقه على هذا المعسكر المعسكر كان
يتبع لجهاز الامن في عهد النظام السابق
وبعد ذلك سيطرت عليه القوات الدعم السريع
واصبح معسكرًا للقوات الدعم السريع تمت
مهاجمه هذا المعسكر منذ اخريات اول ساعات
الاخيره من نهار امس واستمرت هذه الهجمات
خلال الليل حتى الساعات الاخيره تسمع ذوي
الانفجارات
والقنابل وكذا حتى اصوات المدافع الثقيله
على هذا المعسكر السالم فيما يتعلق بردود
الفعل التي صدرت من القوى السياسيه مؤخرا
لك الكثير من ردود الفعل لكن اخر هذه
الردود المتعلقه بتعليقات القوى السياسيه
هل هناك اي تعقيبات جديده من القوى
السياسيه في السودان حول الوضع الحالي
وكذلك تصاعد حده التوترات وايضا القصف
المتبادل ما بين القوى الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني
القوى السياسيه تبدي تاسفها على ما يحدث
وان هذا الذي يحدث ليس في مصلحه احد هذا
ما رددته كثير من السياسيه التي تتحدث عن
على ان هذا الامر ليس فيه كاسب
وان هذه الامور ستسير بالبلاد الى منزل
خطير جدا كان واحد من ردود الفعل واحد من
ردود الفعل عضو مجلس السياده الهادي ادريس
الذكر بانه هذه
المرحله التي يمر بها السودان هي مرحله
مفصليه تتطلب حكمه وعقلانيه وان هذه
الحرمين ينتصر فيها احدها وسنخسر السودان
للابد ناصر الاسره الدوليه للمساعده
الدمويه
ودعم الجيش والدعم السري لوقت العمليات
بتجريب البلاد
ادريس
وهو احد اعضاء اتفاقيه
بعد ذلك وصل الى هذا المنصب للسياده
ارجو ان تبقى معي سالم الهاشمي مراسل
العربيه كما تتابعون الان على الهواء
مباشره اصوات القصف العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم لا تتوقف حتى مع صوت اذان الفجر
الذي ينتظره السودانيون الان ايذانا ببدء
يوما جديد من ايام شهر رمضان التي كان
يتعشم الكثيرون بان تطفي رحمتها
وانسانيتها على القوى التي
احتكمت اخيرا الى السلاح في السودان بكل
اسف
بدايه يوم جديد في السودان للاسف يوم صعب
على كل السودانيين الان حتى هذه اللحظه
اصوات القصف لا تتوقف في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وكذلك في عدد من المدن
الاخرى في ظل عدد من البيانات تخرج من كل
طرف كل طرف يتحدث عن السيطره على مقر
تابعه للطرف الاخر لا توجد حتى هذه اللحظه
الجميع ينتظر
بدايه اليوم الجديد في السودان وربما
تتكشف معه ملامح هذه المعركه التي استمرت
على مدى الساعات الماضيه ويبدو انه من صوت
القصف لا امل في توقف هذه المعركه الان
على الارض لنستمع ايضا للصوت الطبيعي من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وتحديدا من مقر
قياده الجيش السوداني
[موسيقى]
كما تتابعون الان على الهواء مباشره هذا
هو اذان الفجر في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم اذان الفجر في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم يقترن باصوات القصف المدفعي
الثقيل في محيط مقر قياده الجيش السوداني
اذا نذهب الى الخرطوم مره اخرى هذه المره
مع الاستاذه رشا عوض الصحفيه من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم مباشره استاذه رشه يعني
يبدو بان كل النداءات الدوليه والاقليميه
التي صدرت خلال الساعات المؤخره
لم تجد لها صدى عند الاطراف التي تتصارع
الان في السودان هل تعتقدي بانه ساعات
القادمه من الممكن ان تحمل الجديد ام انه
من الممكن ان يكون هناك اسوا مما نراه
الان خلال الساعات المقبله
اه بدعم التحيه لك والتحيه لمشاهدي
المشاهدين الكرام
اعتقد ان الان يعني جنون الحرب بكل اسف
يستشرع بين قيادات الجيش وقيادات الدعم
السريع ويبدو ان كل طرف
يسعى الان لتحقيق انتصارات على الارض
فالمعركه صعبه
والمعركه
تكسير عظام
وهي بالنسبه لمن يقفون خلفها من عناصر
النظام البائد هي الفرصه الاخيره للعوده
الى السلطه والسيطره على الاوضاع في
السودان
وبالتالي الصوره قادمه جدا يعني ليست هناك
اي استجابه
للنداء استوى الانسان يعني فتحي ممرات
امنه
لعبور المواطنين المحتجزين في بعض الاماكن
او
لمرور سيارات الاسعاف
الحرب مسيطره بقوه ونتوقع
تزداد وتيره الحرب حتى هذا اليوم بكل اسف
كلما هي منتشره في كل اجزاء السودان وفي
مناطق حيويه وانت كصحفيه السيده رشا يعني
يبدو وكانه الحرب ليست حرب بالرصاص
والقذائف فقط هناك كذلك حرب اعلاميه
متبادله ما بين الجانبين والان نحن في ظل
هذه البيانات بيانات من الجيش السوداني
وبيانات من قوه دعم السريعه من اين نحصل
على المعلومه الحقيقيه السليمه الفعليه
على ارض الواقع الان في السودان
[تصفيق]
من الصعب جدا في هذه الاوقات
ارجو ان تاتي معي سيده رشا لانه يبدو انه
اصوات القصف تزداد حدتها بشكل كبير الان
في السودان
نستمع معكم الى هذا الصوت الطبيعي
اعود اليك مره اخرى استاذه رشا كان يبدو
انه هناك بزياده في حده القصف الان لكن
كنا نتحدث عن الحرب الاعلاميه التي تدور
الان بين الجانبين وكذلك حرب البيانات من
اين لنا ان نحصل على الحقيقه الان حول ما
يدور فعليا في الشارع السوداني
الانتصارات وان نقول لطرف استولى على مقر
الطرف الاخر ولكن
احجارات التي نستمع الى دويها
الابعاد تدل على ان المعارك مستمره
ومنحط ان
نصدق يعني الروايات روايات الطرفين عن ان
كل من هو مسيطر
هناك قروه فروه وهناك
يعني وانت تتحدثين الان السيده رشا واذان
الفجر الان في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
على الهواء مباشره حتى في لحظات اذان
الفجر لم يتوقف القصف بالاسلحه الثقيله
[موسيقى]
يعني كما تتابعون الان على الهواء مباشره
هذه هي اصوات قذائف الهاون وكذلك اصوات
المدفعيه الثقيله تختلط بصوت اذان الفجر
وكانه صوت اذان الفجر في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وكانه ساعه صفر لانطلاق
معركه لا تنتهي الان في السودان كما
تتابعون الان على الهواء مباشره اصوات
القصف لا تتوقف حتى برغم رفع صوت اذان
الفجر في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ويبدو
وكاننا امام رغبه من كافه الاطراف لمزيد
من التصعيد خلال الساعات القادمه استاذه
رشا يعني يبدو ان الجميع لديه رغبه في
التصعيد خلال الساعات المقبله
يعني هل تحولت صوت اذان الفجر في السودان
للاعلان عن ساعه صفر للمزيد من المعارك
يبدو الامر كذلك
واستمعنا في بيانات
من الجيش ان نقي سوف يقسم المعركه في
السعاده الاولى من فجر هذا اليوم ولكن
يبدو ان المعارك الان
في بدايتها
عن الوضع اخذ في التازم بكل اثم يعني لكن
هنا سؤال استاذه رشا يعني هذه المنطقه
التي نسمع فيها هذا الكم الكبير من القصف
المتبادل بين الجانبين وكذلك القصف
المدفعي وقصف مدفعي ثقيل كما نتابع الان
على الهواء مباشره هي منطقه مقتظه
بالمدارس بالمعاهد بكذلك بالمقرات
الدبلوماسيه
بالاحياء السكنيه يعني كيف للجيش وقوه
الدعم السريع ان تتلاشى وجوه وقوع ضحايا
مدنيين في ظل هذا القصف المدفعي الثقيل
الذي يبدو قصف يعني غير محدد في اتجاهات
غير محدده على ما نرى الان
طبعا نحن في السودان اعتدنا من المؤسسه
العسكريه عدم الاهتمام بارواح المدنيين
يعني هذه ليست الحرف الاولى في السودان
شهدنا في حروب دارفور وحروب جنوب كردفان
والنيل الازرق
والان
تتوافر احصائيات
انها غير دقيقه وانها اقل من الاحصائيات
الحقيقيه بينهم اطفال
وبساء
وبين في هذه المنطقه المقتظه
صحيح في المرافق الحيويه حتى الكثير من
المستشفيات التي تعاني الان من انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي ويعني هناك الكثير من
المناشدات لضروره بضروره عوده التيار
الكهربائي لهذه المستشفيات لانها تعرض
حياه الكثيرين للخطر بشكل فعلي
اكيد في هذه المنطقه بالمناسبه يوجد
مستشفى للقلب ومستشفى
المستشفى الخرطوم التعليمي ويوجد
الافوني محتجزين ايضا يعني
هذه من القياده العامه للجيش في هكذا
منطقه يعني استراتيجيه وحيويه
لشكلات العسكريه ومقام الجيوش تقول في
مناطق طرفيه من المدن ولا تكون داخل المدن
لان مهمه الجيوش اصلا التصدي للعدوان
الخارجي ولكن بكل اسف هناك اختلالات
هيكليه في الدوله السودانيه وهذه
الاختلالات
ترى تتم معالجتها بالحوار
بالاصلاحات المؤسسيه للدوله السودانيه حتى
تكون اكثر حساسيه
لحياه المواطنين ولمصالح المواطنين وامنهم
ولكن ابت حلول النظام البائد التي تحلم
بالعوده
على جماجم السودانيين وجثثهم ابت الا ان
تدخلنا في هذا النفق المظلم الذي نحن
امامه الان
يعني وانت معنا السيده رشا نتابع على
الهواء مباشره من محيط مقر قياده الجيش
السوداني القصف المدفعي الثقيل المتبادل
ما بين القوى الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني في ظل الكثير من البيانات
والمعلومات الوارده من الطرفين ارجو ان
تبقي معي استاذه رشا عوض اذهب الى الاستاذ
خالد الفكري المحلل السياسي السوداني
استاذ خالد يعني هذه الاصوات التي نتابعها
الان على الهواء مباشره هل تبددت كل
الاحلام بالعوده الى المفاوضات السياسيه
او حتى بما يعرف بالاتفاق الاطري
[موسيقى]
سماع صوت البندقيه يعني انا كنت
بحذر
دقيقه منذ الواحده فجرا اجتهاد اطلاق
النيران والدانات والاصوات
والمختلف الاسلحه الثقيله خاصه في مناطق
جنوب العاصمه النحوي اقل من عشره كيلو
لاطباخ وصار كيلو في مناطق كما اشارته
استاذ رشا تضجه في المواقع العسكريه مثل
حيث يعني نحن قريبين منها نسمع اصوات
المدرعات
والتبادل يعني الصغيره
دقه التفاصيل وما هي مدى الاصابات وما هي
مدى دقه
تصور وهل هناك غيوم او الدفاع من كل من
الطرفين هل هناك محاولات للسيطره على
مواقع عسكريه جديده او او محاولات للزود
والدفاع عن مواقع عسكريه
الخرطوم هو اليوم الليل صغير على مواطنيه
الليل مغلق مفزع يعني تكاد تكون كافه
الاسر السودانيه لم تفزع بالراحه
والضمانينه لم تحظى بالذهاب الى صلاله
تهدد في المساجد كالعاده كما تاب
السودانيين يعني ينفقوا في هذه العجله
الاواخر ويصب
للمساجد يتبرعوا لله رب العالمين كل ذلك
كل هذه المظاهر الايجابيه الايمانيه هي
الان تبددت بسبب هذه الحرب اللعينه بسبب
المخاوف من اصطياد يعني بعض الطلقات
الطائشه لاروعهم ربما تحب اليكم هناك صوت
قوي جدا يعني انا الان
ذهبت ودخلت الى داخل اقصى غرفه ممكن يعني
بكل اسف
اصوات القصف تزداد منذ حتى
انطلاق اذان الفجر وبدا اذان الفجر في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم القصف يزداد
بشكل كبير جدا في المحيط مقر قياده الجيش
يعني كنت كنت اود ان اخرج الى الخارج حتى
تسمع الاصوات الاصوات المدافع الشغله بدقه
ولكن اخشى يعني اخشى اخشى من رصاصه طائشه
ولكن دعني اقول لك ان الامر مختلف وان
الصباح يعني الفجر هو الان يقول ولكن نقشه
ان تتحول الخرطوم الى مدينه من الاطلال
والاجباح والخراب
كثير من المقارنه السكنيه الشعبيه والى
وسط العاصمه من المؤسسات الدوله لانهما
يبدو انما يعني هذه الضربات الغازيه
الضربات بالاسلحه الثقيله دون شيء تخلف
دمار عميق في البنى التحتيه وقبل ذلك يعني
قتلى الان يعني اصبحت الاعداد القتلى
مرشحه للزياده والتصاعد بشكل كبير وكذلك
الجرحى دون الوصول الى حقيقه على الابدي
في ظل منع التراغم الميدانيه وحرمانها من
الذين هم الان في مرمى النيران من
المدنيين او من العسكريين في ظل انعدام
وصحه الخدمات الاساسيه المتعلقه بالكهرباء
او التواصل
او التواصل حتى يتم الاقتناء على الاسر
فيما بينها الان واحد من من من
على التوازن بشكل ايجابي
والملاحظه
التفاصيل اذا الان نحن نعيش في في في قلق
وخوف وزهر حقيقي يعني الامر مفزع بعض
الاسر لا تعرف حتى هذه اللحظه مصيره
ابنائيه اين هم منذ الصباح الباكر خرجوا
للعمل
المدارسهم ولكن للاسف الشديد بعض الوزر
الان من اساتذه الجماعات الخرطوم هم يمرمن
النيران داخل ولم يتمكنوا من العوده الى
منازلهم حتى هذه اللحظه
بالكامل
بجوار بجوار منزليه البرهان داخل احياء
المطار وبالقرب من
هذه الاسره الان هي يعني لكن تتخيل هذه
الخالقه بكل تاكيد بين الاصوات الرصاص
طبعا
ارجو ان تبقى معي السيد خالد واذهب الى
الكاتب الصحفي عمرو شعبان يعني استاذ عمرو
انا اعلم بانه المعلومات قليله وكذلك
البيانات تصدر من الجانبين لكن التصعيد
العسكري الان الذي يشتد منذ اكثر من نصف
ساعه وحتى هذه اللحظه يعني ما الذي يسعى
اليه كل طرف من خلال هذا التصعيد العسكري
الان
لقد
خرطوم نصف ساعه الماضيه كما تفضل من الوضع
هو لان الضغط الدولي والاقليمي حسبها نعلم
او حزمه رجع
يمارس على الاطراف حتى
يطيب التصعيد ولربما للجلوس فمن الواضح
انه لتحسين الوقت التفاؤدي اذا كان هنالك
طرف سابقها على الارض
تريد ان تقول بان كل طرف يسعى الى تحقيق
اكبر قدر ممكن من المكاسب على الارض
لتعزيز موقفه في التفاوض
نعم نعم هذا امر يتيح للطرفين ربما فرض
شروطهم والتفاوضيه وتمرير ما يريداني
بعضهم البعض لكن عموما
مواقفهم التفوضيه مع من فيما بينهم فيما
يعني فيما بينهم
[موسيقى]
في المجلس السياده بعد التشكيله المدنية
فانما يرى الطرف العسكري الاخر ان يكون
السيطره عليهم
وهو امر بالتاكيد
من خلاله تاكيد تفوزوا والحفاظ على قوته
وكل منهم
كانت هذه النقطه التي عاصمت بالتفاوض ما
بين الطرفين خصوصا في ظل في ظل تمدد
والانتشار والانفتاح الذي تعمل سريع
الجيش تجاوزا لضوابطه وربما ساهم طرف ثالث
في خلق خصوصا في ظل ضوابط المعلومات وعدم
تاكيدها ربما ساهم الطرف الثالث في لقاع
الفتنه بين الطرفين
واحداد عمليه الاشتباك الجاريه منذ صباح
امس عموما الى
اذا رجعنا للاخر الساعات الماضيه للجيش هو
اخر مره اصدر برنامج
التلاوه على كل مسار الدعم السريع بامانه
التي فيها اكبر معسكرات الدعم السريع
ومعسكر الطاقه
ما ظهر من معلومات او مارشح من معلومات او
بيانات رسميه من الطرف الجيش
فيما يتعلق بحديث الجيش يعني ساعود اليك
فيما يتعلق بالقوه الدعم السريع لكن فيما
يتعلق بحديث الجيش السيد عمرو يعني كان
يتحدث قبل ساعات انه سيحسم هذه المعركه مع
قوه دعم السريع مع الساعات الاولى من صباح
فجر اليوم وكما تتابع يعني على الهواء
مباشره هناك تصاعد في حده الاشتباكات
وكذلك في القصف المدفعي الثقيل
لكن
فيما يتعلق وهذه معلومات يعني فيما يتعلق
بما يمتلكه الجيش من قوه عسكريه على الارض
هل هي قوه تؤهله لحسم المعركه امام قوه
امام قوه غير النظاميه مثل قوه دعم السريع
تعتمد على سياسات ربما تختلف عن السياسات
التي او استراتيجيات لا تلتزم بها الجيوش
النظاميه في كثير من الدول
نعم حرب المدن بالتاكيد من الجيش اسعد من
الحروب الصعبه لانه يعتمد على الصفات
مختلفه تماما عن عرض الم
دن التي تدخل السريع فكانت بحسم مناطق
التمرد في حينما وانشاها النظام البعيد في
فتره
اختلاف لكن دعنا نقول ان في تمام الساعه
العاشره والنصف والحادي عشره مساء عن
الجيش انه سيقوم بتمشيط العاصمه يقوم
بالتبسيط من خلال الطيران لجانبها
المواطنين
يعني ياخذوا حذرهم الى الان لم نستمع الى
صوت طائرات من حادثه الحادي عشره
وحتى الان ربما في الساعات القليل القادمه
او في الدقائق القادمه ربما نشهد هذا
التنشيط الذي يتحدث عنه الجيش وبالتاكيد
تدخل الطيران يعد عمل حاسم لكن بالتاكيد
ايضا ربما عمل حاسم في الحروب التقليديه
لكن عامل ليس بشكل كبير حاسم في الحروب
الشوارع يعني
لا اظن ان الامر سيستغرق اكثر من ست ساعات
حتى تنجلي بوضوح من هو الطرف الذي
مالتك الكفته في هذه المواجهه
اذهب اليك السيد يعني اعود الى الاستاذه
رشا ساده رشا هل تعتقدي بانه مساله
الاحتكام الى السلاح بعد ان باتت امرا
واقعا ستستمر خلال الساعات او ربما الايام
القادمه ام انها من الممكن ان تنتهي خلال
ساعات كما وعد الجيش السوداني
الى السلاح ما دام بدا
فسوف يستمر
حتى لو توقفت المعارك في الخرطوم
المعارك الان في كثير من مدن السودان
[موسيقى]
افتح على الدوله السودانيه ابواب الجحيم
مهما كانت
يه
في التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار فان مستوى
العلاقه بين الجيش والدعم السريع الان وصل
الى نقطه ان لا عوده
فاذا توقفت الحرب في ربما تقود هذه القوات
تمردا في دارفور ولها وجود كبير في تلك
المنطقه ولا يضمن احد
الدنماركيه الخاصه التي ينتجها القتال من
دخول قوه جديده على الخط او انقسامات في
القوه المتقاتله الان يعني نحن امام وضع
غايه في التع
قيد هو وثبت ايادي كل الذين دفعونا الى
هذه الهاويه التي تتحدثين الان الجيش
السوداني يقول اقتربت ساعه النصر
اقتربت ساعه النصر كما يقول الجيش
السوداني عبارات يعني
مرتبطه الان كما تتابعون على الهواء
مباشره بقصف ثقيل قصف مدفعي ثقيل يبدو انه
الجيش السوداني يستخدم رجيمات صواريخ في
هذا القصف المدفعي في محيط مقر قياده
الجيش السوداني بالعاصمه الخرطوم الجيش
السوداني يتحدث ايضا ويقول نبشر شعبنا
الصابر باخبار ساره قريبا
استاذه رشا يعني ما الذي من الممكن ان
يكون في جعبه الجيش السوداني خلال الساعات
القادمه خاصه وهو يقول نبشر شعبنا الصابر
باخبار ساره قريبا
البشير قالوا التمرد في اسبوعين ويرفعوا
لي التمام
ووعدوه بذلك ولكن ما الذي حدث الذي حدث
الحرب دارفور استمرت لعشرين عاما وترتبت
عليها ماساء ثانيه كانت حديث العالم باسره
وبالتالي حروب المواطنين في البلد الواحد
ضد بعضهم البعض ليس فيها منتصر وليس فيها
مهزوم وانما فيها دمار وضياع
للبلد النصر الحقيقي الذي نتطلع اليه
كمواطنين سودانيين
لا ننحاز الى اي طرف في هذا القتال
النصر الحقيقي هو ان يتواطئ الجميع على ان
الوسيله الوحيده المقبوله وهنا من يقول
استاذه رشا انه حتى عدم الانحي في بعض
المواقف يعتبر تواطئ
على السلطه بين النظام الفائد الذي يريد
استغلال عناصره في الجيش في هذا الصراع
قوات الدعم السريع الذي هو الذي انشاها في
الاساس يعني الدعم السريع ليس مسؤوليه
الشعب السوداني او القوى المدنيه
الديمقراطيه هو مسؤوليه النظام البعيد
الان بقت بهم الشغل
مضى الدعم السريع في اتجاه سياسي معاكس
للنظام البائد وبدا ينظر الى النظام
الاسلامي على انه مهدد وجودي له وفي هذا
الاطار هم يشتبهون
الانس صاروا اعداء اليوم يعني
الشعب السوداني متضرر من هذه الحرب ويتمنى
ان تتوق
ف اكثر
ارجو ان تبقي معي استاذ رشا اريد ان يعني
السماع الى استاذ خالد الفكري استاذ خالد
الفكري
لنتابع هذه الصور كما تتابعون الان على
الهواء مباشره ويعني السنه اللهب يعني
هذه صور تحدث
يعني صور منتشره نشرتها قوه الدعم السريع
مقطع فيديو نشرته قوى الدعم السريع تقول
انه ضرب لمقر القوات البريه التابعه للجيش
السوداني كما تتابعون الان على الهواء
مباشره هذه السنه
[موسيقى]
والقوه الدعم السريع تقول بانها
قامت وتمكنت من ضرب مقر القوات البريه
للجيش السوداني في على الجانب الاخر الصور
التي تاتي من مقر القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني هذه رشقات صاروخيه متتاليه
لنستمع ايضا للصوت الطبيعي من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
على الفلاح
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
واياك
صراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
[موسيقى]
كما تتابعون الان على الهواء مباشره هذا
هو اذان الاقامه لصلاه الفجر في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم اذان اقامه صلاه الفجر
الان على الهواء مباشره
ويقترن بصلاه الفجر الان في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم اصوات القصف المدفعي
وقبل قليل تحدثت قوات الدعم السريعه بانها
تمكنت من استهداف مقر القوات البريه في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم قبل قليل ايضا
تحدث الجيش السوداني وقال ان لديه اخبار
ساره للشعب السوداني وان النصر بات قريبا
دون تحديد موعد محدد ويبدو انه ذوي
الاشتباكات العنيفه بالاسلحه الثقيله
مستمر حتى اثناء صلاه الفجر في العاصمه
الخرطوم حتى هذه اللحظه اذهب الى الاستاذ
خالد الفكيه الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
السوداني
استاذ خالد يعني الحديث السياسي دائما ما
يكون صعب اثناء يعني هذه الاصوات من القصف
المدفعي الثقيل لكن الجيش السوداني يتحدث
ويقول نبشر شعبنا الصابر باخبار ساره
قريبا برايك ما هي هذه الاخبار وما الذي
يعنيه الجيش السوداني بكلمه قريبا
نعم يعني اسامه اعتقد
منذ الساعات الاولى
الجيش السوداني اتخذ موقفا في هذه الحرب
وسماها بحرب الكرامه
وربما لاول مره يعني يصف الدم كانت هي جزء
منه
بالمتمرده والعدو وربما هذا يجعله يستخدم
كافه الاسلحه
الثقيله
لملاحظه وضرب اهداف هذه اهداف
المتعلقه بالمواقع الرئيسه لقوات الدعم
السريع ولعل اخرها الذي البيان الذي صدر
في السعاده الاولى من هذا الصباح
تماما على مقر الدعم السريع جنوب جنوب غرب
ام درمان والذي يعد من اكبر المعسكرات
بكافه الاليات وكافه
الاسلحه الثقيله فاتوقع ان تكون المفاجات
والبشريات الساره في هذا السياق هو
الاستيلاء على اكبر قدري من معسكرات
واليات الدعم السريع وربما يعني يعني يعلن
عن توقيف شخصيه بارزه بين ضباط الدعم
السريع او تسليم لبعض مقارنهم كما يعني ظل
الجيش يقول في اللحظات الاخيره من من او
في الساعات الاخيره من عشيه عشيه امس
فبالتالي الان الجيش السوداني ينظر الى
هذه المعرفه بانها مالكه وجوديه تتطلب
التخلص من عده دعم السريع لكن حتى يعني
حتى نكون موضوعيين استاذ خالد كذلك الطرف
الاخر ينظر لها بانها معركه مصيريه
بالنسبه له وبالتالي يعني
كلا من الطرفين لن يسمح او لن يستهين
بالطرف الاخر وبالتالي ربما هذا لا قدر
الله يسمح بمزيد من الاشتباكات ومزيد من
تصاعد حده هذه الاشتباكات ايضا
نعم نعم وهذا ما قاله
انما لن ننسحب ولن نتراجع ولن نتفاوض الا
بعد النصر الى مبتغانا فبالتالي اعتقد ان
كل من الطرفين له مبرراته ولو اهدافه التي
يقول بها ولكن تبقى هناك
تبقى تبقى هناك
العمليات الاضافيه والنوعيه لبعض الوحدات
ربما التي لا تتوفر هنا وهناك يعني نحن
سمعنا ان الدعم السريع اسقط طائره مسيره
في منطقه جري شماليه الخرطوم وربما هذا
لاول مره نسمع عن استخدام الجيش لطائرات
مسيره كان البرهانه قد اعلنا حصول الجيش
وادخاله الى الخدمه قبل نحو شهرين من الان
فاذا الان هناك اليات جديده ووحدات جديده
تنضم الى القتال وربما الجيش اعلنا عن
وحده غير متوفره للدعم السريع وهي وحده
الطيران التي قالت انها حققت ضربات
ايجابيه ومهمه قطعه قطعت طريق امداد الدعم
السريع في مناطق حيويه وتمركزه داخل
الخرمه وفي اطراف الخرطوم حتى لا تصل
الامدادات الى القوه الرئيسيه التي هي
الان تهاجم المقر
الحكوميه
والرياحيه وكانت قصر الجمهوري او القياده
العامه او مناطق اخرى اكثر حيويه فبالتالي
اعتقد ان الفارغ والفيصل في هذه المعرفه
ربما الاسلحه النوعيه المضافه المتوفره
لكل من طرف عند الاخر ربما يعني الدعم
السريع يلجا الى استخدام مضادات الطائرات
المتغير الصغيره
المتعلقه
بالمصادات الاخرى فبالتالي اعتقد ان الان
الاضافه الحقيقيه التي ربما يعني تجعل
الغلبه لاحد من من على الثاني هي الاسلحه
وايضا ربما الجيش قال ان
حفاظه على المواطنين وارواح المواطنين
يمنعه من التغول والدخول والولود في مناطق
يعني يستطيع الدعم السريع ان يتميز بالقصه
والحركه فيها
ولذلك لتكوينه والجيش كما هو معروف يمتلك
مثل المجندرات الدبابات لا تستطيع
الملاحظه والدخول في بعض الطرق او في
مناطق يعني يخشى الجيش ان تكون هناك كما
افخاخ منصوبه له فبالتالي الان يبدو ان
المعركه في هذه اللحظات مع مع الفجر هي
تتكشف بان هناك يعني
قدرات وامكانيات في محاولات التفوق
والسيطره على الارض الميدان ومحاوله لطرف
يحاول ان يعني كل طرف يحاول ان يحصل على
ما يريد من مكاسب قبل ساعات الصباح
القادمه اذهب الى الاستاذ عمرو الشعبان
استاذ عمرو يعني في السودان يتحدثون دائما
في احد الامثال الشعبيه ويقولون الصباح
فضاح برايك ما الذي ستكشف عنه ساعات
الساعات القادمه مع بدايه ساعات الصباح في
السودان
اولا
الطرف الذي يمارس
دعايه او الاعلام والحقيقه يعني يبدو انه
الصوت بعيد قليلا استاذ عمرو
ربما
حقيقه الدعايات التي تم استخدامها قبل
الطرفين ايهما كان دقيقه يوم وكان كاذبا
في عمليه السيطره والاستحواذ ايضا الساعات
القادمه
ستكشف ايضا
له الغلبه في هذا الصراع لكن بالتاكيد
بالتاكيد من ايا كان المنتصر المعزوم
الوحيد هو الشعب السوداني الذي
تعطلت كثيرا بسبب هذه الممارسات الغير
المسؤوله
ايضا ان انتصار انتصار اي طرف من الاطراف
يعني
التمريض مشروع الفوضى التي سيتم استغلالها
من قبل الطرف التالي النظام البارد وفلوله
لعاده الانتاج نفسهم من خلال التوظيف
البندقيه لاعاده استهلاهم ووضع
كما يقولون الرصافه الاخيره في
مشروع الثوره السودانيه التي انقلبوا
عليها اكثر من مره منذ فضل الاعتصام حقيقه
الموقف بالتاكيد يحتاج الى الساعات
القادمه
من خلالها يتم التوثيق للحقائق على الارض
وهو امر بالتاكيد من المهم في ظل هذه
الحرب الاعلاميه الطاووس طيب استاذ عمرو
يعني
فيما يتعلق بالقوه السياسيه ما المطلوب
منها خلال الساعات المقبله وكذلك ما
المطلوب ايضا من المجتمع الدولي والدولي
الاقليميه التي لديها ربما بعض القدره على
ممارسه اي نوع من انواع الضغط على طرفي
النزاع الان في السودان
تشكيل جبهه واسعه وعريضه لا للحرب في
السودان
اثنين
التواصل مع المجتمع الدولي الاقليمي
للاتفاق على حد ادنى ان الطرفين العسكريين
الذين خاضوا هذه المعركه منذ صباح امس
ليسوا معنيين باي عمليه سياسيه منذ هذه
اللحظه سيتم التعامل معهم باعتبارهم
وبالتاكيد لا يتم التعامل معهم ولا يتم
اشتراكم في اي عمليه سياسيه بلوا اخراجهم
المشهد النهائي السياسي نهائيا
باعتبارهم مذنبين ايضا
ربما يتم فرض عقوبات لوحه في ذلك الاتحاد
الاوروبيين بشكل عام لوحوا عن طريق ارسال
اختار للقياده المصريه لانه سيتم
فرضيه عقوبات على الطرف الذي يفعل التطعيم
وهو امر بالتاكيد اذا كانوا جادين فيه
تتوسع هذه الجبهه تضم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيهما يتعلق بمساله العقوبات يعني
هل اتت ثمارها خلال السنوات الكثيره التي
مضت
والسودان حتى النظام السياسي السابق في
السودان لديه خبره كبيره في التعامل مع
مثل هذه الامور وانت تعلم بانه مثل هذه
العقوبات ليست ذات جدوى حقيقيه على ارض
الواقع يعني وهناك تجربه لسنوات في
السودان في هذا الملف
المتضرر الاخير طبعا هو الشعب السوداني
وهذا معلوم
السلاح والنفوز والمال
ومراكز القوه انها تستطيع ان تمثل
السودانيه وتعبر عنهم ايضا كثره العين او
كثره النفس اذا هذا انه لا يستطيع ان
يتحرك مثل ما كان لا يستطيع الرئيس النظام
البعيد ان يتحرك مثل هذه الامور وتقليص
حساباتهم وما نهبوه من اموال الشعب
السوداني ايضا
كشف كشف حقائق معاركهم والتي يخوضونها ان
هي في في محاوله فقط لسرقه المشروع التحول
المدني الديمقراطي لصالح المشروع الامني
بالحفاظ على الامن والاستقرار بضروره وجود
المكونه العسكري
[موسيقى]
وما هو الخيار البديل الخيار البديل هو ان
نحمل نحن ابناء الشعب السوداني في مواجهته
وهذا امر عسكري في الدوله السودانيه
وعسكره الحل السياسي السوداني هو امر يبحث
عنه الكثيرون لتخفيف السودان اذا مررنا
مشروع الجبهه الاسلاميه سابقا مررنا مشروع
الارهاب في المنطقه مررنا مشاريع تؤرق دول
الاقليم
بالتاكيد والسلاح الوحيد والانظمه التي
استطاع ان يكسر كل هذه الانظمه هي سلميه
الشعب السوداني الذي تمسك بها ولا تظلوا
ملتزما بها وحريصا عليها طيله الفتره
الماضيه بالتاكيد لصالح الشعب السوداني
هذه الحرب لا لاحقه فيها ولا جمل كلا
الطرفين ندعي عليهما في هذه الساعات
المباركه الظالمين بالظالمين وخرجنا منهم
سالمين كل المناسقه بانه يعني سماحه الشعب
السوداني وما عرف به من
مسالمه ستنتصر في نهايه هذا المطاف ارجو
ان تبقوا معي جميعا ضيوف الكرام الان
سنذهب الى الزميل صهيب شراير مره اخرى
ومتابعه لهذه التغطيه الحيه لاخر الاخبار
المتعلقه بالتطورات الميدانيه في الشارع
السودانيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات